[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local aujourd'hui il y aura comme
toujours des analyses des débats et des
duels endiablé quatre chroniqueurs sont
autour de 7 ha pour m'accompagner
présentation de là à donner une team on
commence à ma droite à nous vient tout
droit de versailles est aussi pétillante
que pertinente à des spécialistes de
pole dance on est toujours heureux de la
voir sur ce plateau notre ambassadrice
de charme
hélène de la grange ont été définis je
me suis ravi d'être encore parmi vous
donc j'en connais pas très bien
j'attendais les duels j'attends
j'attends
vous êtes en pleine forme je suis on
passe de l'autre côté musique il fête
aujourd'hui son sixième passage dans
cette émission il est aujourd'hui devenu
un titulaire dans cette équipe
chevronnée il aime distiller les
analyses pertinentes quand allez-vous
stéphane devisé à eau près tous tombés
aujourd'hui je vous ai une entrée
fracassante en temps là ça fait du bruit
c'est tout ce qu'ils font alors vous
êtes amateur de samba basket rugby
football
voilà deux tours en donner tout ce qui
tout qui tout ce qui peut se pratiquer
je le fais parfait on passe de l'autre
côté et je suis vivant et je jugerai
vivant vous résistez on passe de l'autre
côté à musique qui nous vient lui aussi
du grand test versailles et sa
spécialité le rugby mais il aime
également le golf le football les sports
automobiles la course à pied et le
lancer d'espadrilles en vacances c'est
notre couteau suivi sans le surnomme le
gallia teurs pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles formé bonheur
quand allez-vous ça va très bien résumé
parfait effectivement je coûte peut-être
placé quelques nappes étant que si à
pétanque également quelques autres sport
la natation le papillon surtout je suis
très très bon et
la course à pied ou se nomme michael
phelps au niveau de la taille et du de
l'est l'ont sage c'est bien cela on
passe de l'autre côté musique lui aussi
aime participer au concours de lancer
d'espadrilles ils aiment tirer droit est
loin ils recherchent surtout la
performance
il est spécialiste rugby également
genlis la légende est avec nous bonjour
à tous vos joues rick l
comment allez-vous gens une forme pareil
vous êtes spécialistes rugby
oui monsieur lancer d'espadrilles je
t'entends officialiste c'est un grand
mot mais bon passionné oui on nous les
brouillons on va bien veut dire que l'on
connaît un petit peu quoi alors avant de
passer au programme de l'émission on
commence par du rugby la tempête n'a pas
arrêté à lui verser 60 18 à montigny le
bretonneux ce dimanche 1er mars l'union
rugby centre 78 est parvenu à jouer avec
les éléments pour s'imposer dans un
match à sens unique contre melun combs
ce sénat score final 42 à 0 avec six
essais à la clé l'équipe se relance
après sept matches sans victoire
réaction les conditions étaient assez
extraordinaire on a retrouvé enfin
l'importance qu'ont d'artois la victoire
je ne vais pas gagner et on va dire que
les conditions nous obliger à nous
resserrer à jouer de manière plus
solidaire et c'est pas plus c'était
peut-être un mal pour un bien
mais on va s'en souvenir de ce match
parce que les conditions étaient assez
incroyable des conditions de jeu inédite
qui ont fait de la casse chez les
adversaires les visiteurs ont dû
déclarer forfait avant la fin du match à
cause de plusieurs reprises blessures
regarder
il ya eu plein de problèmes et de
l'arbitré qui a eu un problème également
et ensuite l'équipe adverse qui était
pas suffisant
et voilà mettions le score était déjà
fait en soi donc ça ne change pas
grand-chose à la logique du match gens
que vous en pensez de ces conditions
climatiques
j ai des conséquences de ces conditions
j étais aussi dessous et dans des
conditions encore plus pas mon team
parmigiani mai
sur le terrain'' de gif-sur-yvette cité
est encore pire puisque là ils ont joué
sur leur synthétique et nous on était
sur un terrain en herbe
donc je vous laisse imaginer le résultat
avec les conditions climatiques qui a eu
ce dimanche là c'était un bourbier et
j'avais très longtemps que j'avais pas
vu ça on a toutes les élections à la
neige alors très peu non on n'en parle
pas trop de blessures mais melun et est
venue est venu à ric rac a eu à lui
verser 60 18 carats quatre forfaits en
réserve ils n'avaient pas de qui
préserve et très très peu en première
donc après malheureusement et c'est vrai
que ça va très vite en dessous de 11
joueurs
le match était obligé de s'arrêter c'est
ce qui leur est arrivé donc ils ont un
match perdu avec moins de points en plus
il n'a pas besoin de sable suisse on est
dernier au classement mais voilà mais
les conditions étaient été vraiment
exceptionnel c'est vrai également à
versailles on n'aura pas le week-end
dernier mais le week end avant sur le
terrain de oui d'ailleurs ça nous a
coûté une belle déculottée et c'est vrai
que ça nous rappelle que le rugby est un
sport d'hiver c'est pas le ski c'est pas
c'est pas le patinage artistique mais
c'est c'est un sport d'hiver qui se joue
tout en tout-terrain argent on parlait
désormais il ya certains certaines
surfaces qui ont évolué avec maintenant
des matches qui se jouent sur
synthétique homologué donc qui
permettent quand même d'avoir un jeu qui
est à peu près aéré mais quand on joue à
l'ancienne comme nom inconnu sur des
terrains en herbe de terre de boue et et
d'herbes c'est c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué lorsque versailles à jouer à
où il ya quinze jours on a une ou des
quêtes d'hypothermie c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est ce qu'il faut noter et
c'est une des grandes premières alors là
il ya des blessures pour lui versait ya
des blessures et des faits de jeu qui
sont des blessures plus tôt musculaire
ou des peines qui sont un peu débiles du
côté de melun là pour nous l'un est là
pour le coup on a connu des cas
d'hypothermie avec avec vraiment de
températures basses du vent de la pluie
c'est là ma nage c'est la même chose et
la neige ou du grésil
c'est la même chose les conditions sont
les mêmes pour les deux équipes mais
pour le coup là non là c'est qu'elle a
vécu à ce point l'attention de tous le
froid le vent le grésil et la pluie mais
dans avait connu un jeune alors oui
c'est vrai mais mais un conseil son
cours ou bien il ya des joueurs en fin
de match à la fin du match les joueurs
des joueurs sont ont pas fait deux
dollars et du tout tout le monde est
rentré en courant sous la douche et il y
avait des joueurs en fin de match qui
était il l'a dit pierre frigorifié qui
était vraiment ils n'ont pas pu mais
alors que on le sait dès qu'on fait du
sport on se réchauffe rapidement et
après c'est terminé mais là étant
trempée par la pluie le froid le vent la
neige fait c'étaient des conditions
assez particulier dernier dimanche la
semaine dernière et celui et la semaine
d'avant c'était c'était totalement
exceptionnel en termes de conditions en
ile de france il ya du avoir d'autres
d'autres régions concernées mais
effectivement c'est assez assez inédit
des femmes diviser ce qu'il fallait à
arrêter la rencontre ne pas jouer la
rencontre
peut-être je pense que ça aurait été du
football ça aurait été purement et
simplement annulée ç'a été annulés dans
la plupart des cas revoilà après ça
n'enlève pas la victoire à lui verser et
sans détails en plus mais moi j'aime
bien ce rugby dans la boue dans le
passât j'aime bien c'est l'esprit rugby
face et l'esprit rugby sas et c'est bien
elaine hess qu'il fallait annuler les
matches peut-être
je pense qu'on peut pas vraiment il ya
aussi la capacité des joueurs à
supporter la situation ça on peut pas
trop trop présumé l'évolution aussi du
temps au fur et à mesure du match
et puis c'est délicat parce que on peut
si on annule il faut quand même annulé
pas mal de temps à l'avance donc je sais
pas si abraham la dernière minute si je
comprends c'est je pense encadrent
vraiment de force majeure oui mais ça
peut se tenter ça joue après c'est des
efforts fournis beaucoup plus intense
une récupération beaucoup plus délicate
des risques de blessures plus fort voilà
c'est à prendre en ligne de compte
jean vous parliez de des terrains pour
la rencontre ou d'annuler la rencontre
faut savoir quand même qu'un arbitre
puisque là il n'ya que l'arbitré
officiel du match qui peut prendre ce
genre de décision et il ne peut le faire
qu'à travers les règlements de la
fédération française de rugby et
effectivement elle c'était assez
déplorable comme comme climat mais ça
n'était pas injouable quoi et c'est
surtout c'est surtout fait pour la
protection des joueurs ce genre de
décisions lorsqu'on refuse on annule où
on arrête de jouer un match c'est pour
la sécurité le joueur ou parce que il ya
plus de visibilité à plurielles par
exemple des grosses tempêtes de neige
moi ça m'est arrivé au cours d'un match
une énorme tempête de neige est là
l'arbitré arrêtait la porte après
situation un petit peu cocasse larbitre
est un malade est tombé malade pendant
la route c'est vrai tu es tombé sa
rencontre pour lui il est tombé malade
pendant la rencontre
bon quand même il a été remplacé ce qui
est du vent en poupe et vaudou lassus
recevrez une hypothermie
non mais cette saison il s'était écoulé
sont les mêmes pour vers les acteurs les
acteurs du match de rugby il arrive
d'arthrite un désaccord il ne peut une
peule
arrêté que par cas particulier dernière
question est ce que les joueurs vont
s'en souvenir de cette rencontre
oui il a bien d'autres idées et c'est
comme ça me fait penser à des ad des
issues de match comme on a pu connaître
les dernières avec versailles où ça
finit aux tirs au but
cd situation assez inédite dont on se
souvient assez souvent surtout quand ça
gagnait ça irrégulière c'est l'éternité
alors mr ministre qui avait terminé un
32e de finale de championnat de france
en au tirs au but les deux équipes
n'avaient pas pu se départager et c'est
des pénalités qui sont qui sont tentés
et ça ça arrive une fois tous les tous
les 20 ans 30 ans là des conditions
comme ça ça se reproduira mais le
scénario global et l'addition de toutes
les conjonctures ça doit être assez
assez mémorable ça a été quelque part
l'occasion de vivre l'expérience d'un
match compliqué au niveau de la météo et
d'aller jusqu'au bout du match devoir
d'aller dans ses ressources a créé une
expérience
oui j'ai envie de tourner la page je
pense alors nous avons maintenant passer
au programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
nous allons parler du corona virus des
dizaines d'événements sportifs ont été
annulées dans les yvelines
nous parlerons également des
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste les ignobles les illinois n'ont
pas forcément brillé sur cette
compétition mais avant de développer ces
thèmes
on va parler à cyclisme
[Musique]
on commence donc par du cyclisme sur
route la 78e édition du paris-nice est
parti ce dimanche 8 mars depuis les
yvelines dix sept équipes ont pris le
départ de l'épreuve à plaisir les
organisateurs avaient concocté une
boucle de 154 km dans les yvelines en
passant par montfort l'amaury touahri ou
encore neauphle-le-château on écoute le
responsable de la course françois
lemarchand
on a fait un parcours avec des
changements de direction constants on
sait à peu près depuis depuis quelques
années que qu'il ya cette époque de
l'année ya beaucoup de vent donc on
essaye de mettre les coureurs en
difficulté et on avait aussi pas mal de
petites grimpettes sympathique pierre
chevallier un parcours qui vous a
convaincu parce que c'est passé juste à
côté de vendée au coeur du village de
crespières pour le site et voilà c'est
ils sont là soir pierre chevallier le
week-end il habite à crépy ils sont
passés ils sont passés ils ont traversé
le village et après les petites routes
que je fais en cours en voie pavée au
même courant et donc c'était c'était
voilà voilà des conditions dont ils ont
aussi qu'ils ont aussi subi comme les
rugbymans parce que là là au moment où
ils sont passés notamment à crêpière
noces le pen isis et intendants thèse
qui avait appuyé au travers du vent et
quand ils ont commencé à faire les
premiers les premières petites collines
et où les grimpettes que citer le le
directeur de l'épreuve
ça a piqué un petit peu là il vous voyez
les coureurs se secouer les mains parce
qu'il n'avait pas forcément prévu de
partir avec des gants d'hiver ans qu'ils
avaient juste les petites mitaine je me
souviens d'aller philippe qui secoue et
les mains qui sentait plus ses doigts a
priori donc eux aussi ont subi des
conditions
mais au final un bel événement populaire
comme on en voit souvent autour de la
petite reine dans les ive et un beau
tracé stéphane de bizet qui met en
valeur aussi le département le
patrimoine
oui bien sûr c'est dommage que ce soit
sous une tempête mais
oui ça permet de voir un peu le paysage
est ce que là aussi jean c'est pas aussi
l'occasion quand on a des conditions
comme celles-là de créer du spectacle
aussi les organisateurs l'ont dit plus
ou moins au mois de mars il fait pas
forcément super beau dans les yvelines
et il faut exprès de tracer tout
simplement un parcours où il ya du vent
où il pourrait y avoir de la pluie des
conditions compliquées
j'ai pas si loin explique pardon audi a
dit je te prie je veux dire je sais pas
s'ils font exprès de faire en fonction
de la météo
non mais certains certains tracés
étudiés pour le vent par exemple un bon
départ policiers pour qu'ils aient des
conditions météorologiques défavorables
ou favorable là c'était le cas et ils
sont pas gentils gants avec eux mais
c'est déjà assez dur comme ça mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya pire l'a souligné c'était
vraiment des conditions particulières
pour pratiquer cette discipline et il
rigolait pas trop quand même les quoi je
pense que c'est ils vont aussi ça
rappelait on parlait du rugby tout à
l'heure mais aussi votre ça vaut un
souvenir de cette étape et les cinq ans
du spectacle du paris nice il s'utilise
aussi voilà il s'agit pas de faire du
vélo que quand il fait beau c'est c'est
tous les paysages c'est tout les
dénivelés c'est toutes les conditions
météo aussi donc ça fait partie pour moi
de de la pratique du cyclisme / tour
compétition
alors c'est finalement le champion
d'allemagne maximilien sharman qui
s'impose sur la ligne d'arrivée à
plaisir on écoute bien sûr je suis très
heureux c'est ma première fois ici sur
cette course c'était génial
le chouchou du public français julian
alaphilippe termine lui à 4e je suis
content d'avoir fait un beau final
on a fait une course offensive hollande
est toujours vigilants dans les bordures
et donner le maximum
vous avez bien j'ai eu à la flip autour
de cette table
oui oui on va dire que c'est le futur
grand champion français qu'on attend
depuis un moment go et est très très
vite à mon avis très très vite
il est passé où elle l'an dernier dis
donc je pense que je pense que cette
année le tour de france vers leur côté
avec lui et pour revenir à eau paris
nice là l'allemand qui finit sharman
c'est sa femme qui finit premier là
c'est normal qu'ils étaient contents
mais puisqu'un à l'ennui pour lui s'il
faisait beau il faisait beaucoup sur le
parcours ya pas mal d il y avait pas mal
d'équipements moins je suis justement on
va en parler
juste après la petite france voilà où en
fait vous fait un petit saisit alors le
lendemain l'étape est partie en tout cas
depuis chevreuse une petite commune de
moins de 6000 habitants direction le
loiret pour les coureurs
c'est aussi ça la magie du paris nice
suite chevreuse et moins dans le vélo et
je viens toujours voir le paris nice se
regarde toujours mais ma télé mais la
lucette d'apparat chevreuse c'est mieux
on voit tout le monde on voit les
voitures les vélos
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec avec
raymonde
non pas suffisamment souvent grand fan
de cyclisme mais mais on en parle très
souvent parce que les yvelines sur une
terre de vélo
on a la chance d'avoir énormément de
d'événements et de point de départ de
villes étapes ou de devis le départ pour
le tour de france pour le paris nice
parce que parce que le la topographie
s'y prête
en plus ils ont l'embarras du choix de
mettre des traces est plus ou moins
difficiles plus ou moins exposés au vent
et eau et aux éléments climatiques
et puis ça fait plaisir à raymond d un
mode ce qui fait plaisir à raymond c'est
un peu ça ne peut que me rendre vous a
beaucoup plu raymonde également la
raison quand elle dit qu'elle est ravie
que c'est mieux en vrai qu'à la télé
tous les sports quand on peut les voir
en vrai et qu'on peut être plus proche
des participants des joueurs des
compétiteurs c'est plus intéressant
je vous ai dit que ça faisait cinquante
ans qu'elle attendait le paris nice dans
son village garden gens répondent aussi
mais j'ai la fabuleuse fabuleuse dans le
monde et 51 kanata heureusement elle l'a
vu avant c'est génial pour l échange des
parties de cartes à l'ehpad bidon de
chevreuse en tout cas nous sommes à
préciser alors sujet forcément moi moins
radieux l'autre actualité de ce paris
nice était forcément ce corps à la virus
cette équipe ont déclaré forfait juste
avant le début de l'épreuve ce qui a
chamboulé l'organisation des grands
coureurs comme bernal le vainqueur du
dernier tour de france n'ont pas pu
venir
plusieurs mesures ont été mises en place
on écoute les réactions il a fallu
prendre tout un tas de mesures faire
tout un tas de deux chamboulement donc
on a eu une semaine dernière très très
très agitée
là on n'est pas encore sera 100% on
conte on sait qu' il faut vivre au jour
le jour
mais on fait le maximum on prend des
mesures ouais y'a quelques rôles et
quelques règles différentes ou voilà on
n'a pas trop droit de signer
d'autographes
mais sinon depuis le départ de chevreuse
ce lundi les villages départ et
d'arrivée sont à lui cause un huis clos
sans public le peloton devrait quand
même arrivé à nice la question sur ce
thème la fête at elle été gâchée dans
les yvelines ans je parle oui le
partager pierre enfin un petit duel
entre vous stéphane et pierre chevallier
stéphane comment sa chute oui je pense
que ça a été gâchée parce que il n'y a
pas de public au départ il ya pas le
public à l'arrivée ça casse un peu le
charme de cette course
et puis non pour moi c'est devenu
comment dire des coureurs qui font leur
balade du dimanche en fait c'est tout si
il faut le public pour pousser comme au
foot on a besoin d'eux pour je vois je
fais du rugby fauteuil
des fois on a des coups de mou il ya le
public qui pousse et c'est autre chose
moi je pense que ça a été bien engagée
ça n'a pas été gâchée sur l'ensemble du
tracé qu'il y avait effectivement sur le
départ et l'arrivée c'est confinement
qui qui écarté le public siffle public
précise raymonde et moi la nouvelle on
était là on était là ça n'a pas
complètement c'est le lendemain ou la 3e
étape où il ya eu justement celui tout
voilà et donc donc au moins sur nous sur
le départ de la course il ya eu du monde
donc sur la première étape il ya eu du
monde sur le tracé c'est plus les
conditions climatiques que les que les
mesures de confinement qui ont éloigné
le public nombreux
d
des routes mais il est vraiment les
vrais passionnés comme raymonde et elle
a été là au tour donc fait fait
légèrement légèrement modifié pas
forcément gâché mais plus par l'absence
aussi de certaines équipes et certaines
tête d'affiche que que que de que de
vrais de vrais absence d' occasion pour
le public de communier donc je pour ça
que j'étais partagé c'est évidemment
c'est pas c'est pas le c'est pas la
caravane et c'est pas 2 c pas la ville
départ qu'on connaît d'habitude sur du
paris-nice au sur 1 sur un tour de
france mais il ya quand même eu des
occasions de communier avec le public
les des conditions climatiques ont fini
sur le tracé sur le tracé ont fini de
toucher un petit peu justement les
passions les espoirs des plus des moins
motivés les plus motivés et hello alone
pourquoi on a des équipes qui ont
déclaré forfait
alors certes mais ça va parler
c'est plutôt ça monte à cause du courant
à virus il ya eu 2 portal les directeurs
sportifs d'ineos également mais il ya
les coronavirus qui était pris aussi en
considération mais je trouve que c'est
enfin c'est presque eu les moins
finalement les moins touchés les moins
les moins concernés ils sont dehors ils
sont pas en compte afin qu'ils
commencent a été justement dit dans le
reportage
ils sont ils peuvent être écartés du
public resté suffisamment loin faire
quand même la course c'est plutôt ça moi
qui l'embêtent que finalement le fait
qu' il ya des cordons de sécurité
étaient gâchés avant selon mais oui oui
je pense que les conséquences sont pas
juste sur la fréquentation par le public
aussi par les besoins au niveau du
nombre de participants des équipes
participantes
c'est ça qui m'a ça qu'il en est elle
arrivée il y avait quand même un peu le
monde ou personne y avait un peu de mon
dos au but il avait dû vraiment
collectivement un plaisir qu'une arrivée
où il ya personne c'est chaud il y avait
un petit peu de mon dos et à la folie
amy avait quand même un peu de monde et
qu'est ce qu'on pensait gens disent
qu'on pensait de tout ce qui s'est passé
autour des coureurs laissez-les fiq ont
été interdits les autographes et un
petit cordon de sécurité qui a été mis
aussi en place pour éviter que les
spectateurs approche de trop près les
coureurs sous mais fou mais c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu logique
toutes les précautions comprend
actuellement qu'une couronne à virus on
peut pas on peut pas blâmer les
organisateurs de protéger des sportifs
je pense que généralement je dois il le
disait j'ai plus que le coc car je vois
qu'il le disait rien de côté c'est ça
qui le disait tout à l'heure un
reportage
il n'avait pas le le bain de foule
habituelle avec les selphy les
autographes
tout ça alors c'est vrai que c'est
certainement un peu de frustration
supplémentaire pour le public mais après
il faut quand même aussi reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
d'événements de ce sportif ou même
artistique qui sont annulés donc là
c'est quand même
c'est ils le font quand même donc il
faut il faut savoir aussi mais respectez
les sportifs et puis dire voilà on les
protège un petit peu mais on les voit
qu'un passé donc à la fête et pas
totalement gâchée quand tout le monde a
été content pour les médias c'est aussi
particulier parce que je crois que je
composerai plupart des coureurs sont
joints par téléphone qui sont mediapad à
part peut-être vous qui avez eu vos
équipes qui ont pu approcher et fils
mais je crois que pour la plupart du
peloton c'était c'est après ces des
interviews par téléphone où ils ont
résidé au maximum de lézinnes table vite
et il faut faire avec toute logique la
classique actuelle appelée par rapport
aux organisateurs est ce que vous pensez
que c était un casse-tête pas possible
pour sa part ça pas dû être simple à
traiter comme le dit lui rappelé hélène
aux derniers mois plus tôt un petit peu
dans l'urgence en fonction de la
fonction des derniers des derniers
arrêté pris au niveau préfectoral et
notamment les rassemblements de plus de
1000 personnes
la priorité c'est le cas et est donc de
faire avec les annulations les puits les
aléas
là on est dans un cas on est dans un cas
là aussi inédit d'une épidémie jeu
contre lequel face à laquelle on s'est
pas fait un pas quoi faire exactement
en tout cas le paris nice reviendra en
2021 dans les yvelines la course au
soleil devrait rester dans le
département jusqu'en 2025 au minimum on
continue à parler de ce corps là virus
une annulation de dernière minute le
mondial du golf qui devait se tenir pour
la deuxième année consécutive du 19 au
21 mars au parc des expositions de
mantes-la-jolie sur l'îlot mot n'aura
pas lieu les organisateurs ont annoncé
dans un communiqué vouloir prendre
toutes les précautions face au risque le
mondial du golf avait attiré 8000 700
visiteurs line dernière espérant attirer
14000 pour cette édition 2020 à manque à
gagner compris entre 100 et 200 mille
euros
ils devraient y veiller également y
avoir de la course à pied avec la 13e
édition de l'eco trail de paris
mais les organisateurs ont décidé de
reporter l'épreuve à cause du courant la
virus cinq distances étaient pourtant
programme dont 1 80 km au départ de
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines ce samedi les centaines de
coureurs présents devaient ensuite
rejoindre le premier étage de la tour
eiffel au rendez-vous et déplacé au
samedi à 3 octobre
enfin le grand match de volley ball
entre paris et tours programmée fin mars
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a lui aussi
été annulé et devait y avoir près de
5000 personnes dans l'enceinte pour
battre le record de fréquentation
ce qui est dommage c'est que la campagne
d'affichage a débuté ce lundi 9 mars
dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines
le match sera reporté à une date
ultérieure la question sur ce thème
est-ce que c'était la bonne décision de
reporter tous ces événements reportés ou
annulés
oui j'en vous êtes le pieux non mais ça
c'est si et ce soit mais pourquoi parce
que parce qu'ils n'ont pas trop le choix
en plus passé s'est imposée s'est imposé
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on dit que tout
rassemblement depuis mille personnes est
interdite en milieu confiné donc on ne
peut pas le dernier en date que vous
avez cité le match de volley ball où il
venait battre le record est ce que vous
n'avez pas encore le spectateur va à
l'encontre ce qui vient d'être décidé
par mesure de précaution donc c'est ils
n'ont pas le choix ils pourront leur
donne leur dit pas si vous voulez mais
vous pouvez leur portée après certain
c'est que les décisions avant les
annonces par exemple mondial du golf y
avait ces les organisateurs avaient
annoncé cela juste avant oui mais parce
que et peut-être quelques années parce
que la pollution
l'évolution malheureusement elle va pas
va pas du bon côté et qu' on était parti
sur ses mines on savait pertinemment que
ça allait diminuer jusque si ça continue
il y aura au niveau yvan qui vont même
interdire tout rassemblement sportif
1740 france je le rappelle et 33 morts à
l'heure actuelle ce mercredi 11 mars
pas un sport de contacts donc c'est même
sûr n'a pas de public il ya quand même
quelque part un risque on peut
comprendre que ça s'annule
par contre le golf la ja du monde 4
environ il ya deux traitements
différents selon les événements c'est
soit l'annulation soit le report pour le
salon du golf pas le sort du lot le tarn
le mondial du golf
sam 7 avant le monde et du golfe ya en
fait deux raisons principales à ce cette
annulation parce qu'ils ont choisi
d'annuler la première et la principale
c'est que la plupart des exposants
venaient d'asie
donc il ya beaucoup de fabricants de
fournisseurs qui viennent et qui
viennent de chine de corée logique du
japon et comme c'est le sait le berceau
le berceau de ce corner actuellement il
a été jugé sage de ne pas prendre de
risques de ce côté là évidemment
la deuxième raison c'est que c'est il y
aurait eu plus de 1000 personnes
au même moment sur ce salon et ce
mondial donc c'était vrai c'était la
deuxième raison après il ya ceux qui
prennent la décision de reporter c'était
le cas pour le marathon de paris
notamment
mais le semi de paris a été annulé
purement et simplement
c'est le cas pour le tournoi des six
nations où c'est reporté après la seule
chose c'est que il va y avoir un il va y
avoir ils veulent évidemment une une
bouteille âge au niveau des dates dans
le deuxième semestre
en espérant que ce que cette psychose
s'arrête le plus vite possible
ça peut être définitivement annulées
également voilà il ya ce qui fait dire
ce qu'il n'y a nulle direct parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autres possibilités il ya
ceux qui n'ont plus le choix dans la
date est qui et qui le reporte donc de
ce côté-là nous voilà deux traitements
différents de gérer les événements de
toute façon il y aura plus de place il y
aura qu une place dans le calendrier
deuxième semestre pour tous les
événements les coffrets je sais pas s'il
reporte aussi alors reportée au samedi 3
octobre de conneries en revanche ce qui
est bien pour nous entre guillemets on
va avoir une actualité sportive
extrêmement chargée en septembre octobre
novembre a priori on va pas dormir la
csu partout les a été reporté
pour pour match de paris se mettre en
règle ou alors pour l'instant c'est
reporté mais pareil c'est la même chose
ça pour être totalement annulée si les
conditions de l'assaut mais n'y a rien
qui est des instants et ils ont offert à
tous ouais donc pour l'instant ça va
pandora l'eco-trail agents justement
l'eco-trail c'est en extérieur est ce
que c'était aussi la bonne décision
d'annuler comme pour le la il est comme
pour le gimmick paris non il remporté le
semi marathon marathon le smi est annulé
ce biais le smi est annulé mais le souci
le souci c'est que comme l'a dit pierre
sait comment donner à vouloir tout
reporter il va avoir trop mais vu que
c'est en extérieur l organisation que
l'on vous vous pensez qu alors là je
pense que là je vous avais parlé des
rassemblements de milltown la chance que
c'est plus du côté sportif que ça a été
purement et simplement annulé ou un coût
que au niveau de la date
là c'est un choix un choix sportif donc
après je n'ai pas les tenants et des
aboutissants du motif pour lequel ils
ont ils ont annulé plutôt que leur
portée c'est tout le fou qui tourne
autour de ça de cette traitement de
crise sanitaire
c'est que ya quinze jours par exemple on
allait sur les gros événements
il ya le match racing 92 la rochelle qui
s'est tenue à l'aréna paris la défense a
rien à vous gaver a priori 15000
personnes comme ça et le lendemain le
semi de paris en plein air qui est
annulé donc c'était c'est assez c'est
assez anxiogène où c'est assez c'est
assez difficile de s'y retrouver
je crois que ce qui prime là c'est le
côté totalement inédit de cette crise
et justement les décisions qui se
prennent un petit peu au dernier moment
aux fonctions de en fonction des enjeux
il ya et de ceux qui ont le pouvoir de
décision au niveau plus local
hélène par exemple dans vos cours de
pole dance est ce qu'il ya moins de
monde ou pas du tout j'ai pas non moi
j'ai pas forcément moins de monde en
fait
pourtant les bouleversements
rassemblement de moins de 1000 personnes
donc ça va même sur une semaine mais non
non ça va j'ai pas de psychose
particulière je ressens pas ça après je
pense qu'on commence
il commence à avoir un peu de psychose
mais je suis pas encore je le vois pas
arriver jusque dans ma salle et sur le
tard au rugby ça se passe comment là là
on a on a tous des matchs à jouer
dimanche
on a on a sept cette base de pouvoir de
décision il de dire que ya rarement plus
de 1000 personnes sur un match en
devenant confédéral de même en fédérale
3 la question se pose sur les huit clos
où sir les reports à partir de là au
mieux la fédérale 2 vraisemblablement
plutôt fédéral une pro d2 et aux 14
il n'y a pas eu de perturbations si au
niveau des joueurs aussi sur le terrain
non à lisandro pour l'instant non pas
deux
pas de cas pas de cas avérés est pour
l'instant on va dire que le sport joue
plutôt sur une possibilité d'aller
prendre l'air et de se dépenser de
transpirer sens en choper de virus
mauvais ou malin stéphane de bizet ou
dans leurs 10 sport bon oui on a eu un
tournoi qui n'ont pas été perturbés là
ce week-end de hand fauteuil
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent diminuer
le nombre d'handicapés entre en jeu
moi je me pose la question parce qu'au
niveau 10 sport tout et tout et tout et
tout et comme on résiste ils nous auront
pas mais est-ce que tout est comme avant
vous avez des consignes des choses comme
ça peut-être non kim sung à l'isie
toucher vous d'échangé pour désinfecter
vous effectué chaque fois comme là-bas
c'est bon mais on a posé la question
est-ce que tu as prévu de quoi
désinfecter encore plus sa valeur de
métro saddat alors là et puis bon si si
après juste la question de joie quand
j'étais élève qui sont qui annule parce
que elles sont un peu malades elles sont
un peu ceci cela voilà toutes celles qui
sont un petit peu malade qui se sentent
pas bien elle décide de ne pas venir
donc tant mieux mais je pense que c'est
le principe de précaution si j'étais
heureux de vous connaître
on avait un tout le complète de rugby
fauteuil ça m'a plu j'espère vous revoir
ses quatre informé sur l'évolution de ce
courant la virus et les annulations
sportif dans le 7-8 sport ou sop sport
en passe maintenant notre page résultats
[Musique]
on continue par du cyclisme sur piste
les championnats du monde se sont
déroulés à fin février à berlin l'équipe
de france a connu des résultats mitigés
en remportant 5 médailles dont une en or
la plus belle performance et celle de
l'ancien trappistes benjamin thomas qui
a remporté l'or sur l'omnium
mais c'est à peu près la seule
réjouissance de ca championnats du monde
on écoute l'analyse de jean michel
richefort mans à la fédération française
de cyclisme
je crois que il ya vraiment un bon
groupe mais il faut être conscient que
toutes les nations à cinq mois des jeux
olympiques sont déjà un très haut niveau
et d'ailleurs nos pistard progressnow
pistard battent leur record personnel
mais les autres nations sont préparés et
l'année des jeux olympiques les niveaux
de performances sont très très élevé
alors maintenant mais il reste encore à
travailler il reste cinq mois cinq mois
pour atteindre l'objectif suprême pour
être tout à fait complet un mari le net
et clara copponi du vc le sky a remporté
l'argent sur l'américaine bonne nouvelle
pour le kilomètre avec la belle médaille
d'argent de quentin lafargue le pistard
du vaisseau sky et le plaisir aux à
michael d'almeida à lui a terminé 3e
ermenault remporte lui le bronze en
poursuite
la question sur ce thème peut-on être
déçu de ces un résultat en année
olympique
oui non fait un petit duel entre jean et
pierre
tiens vous commencez d'enchères jeudi
que en année olympique
vaut mieux se vautrer l'a pas
lamentablement vaut mieux de votre et
sur les sur les championnats qui précède
même si c'est un championnat du monde et
championne d'europe
je précise que les championnats du monde
sont organisées à tous les ans en city
ce monsieur n'à et j ai donc si ça peut
augurer d'une d'une vraie préparation
parce que justement la douche froide
prépare mentalement à la suite et aux
jeux olympiques et donc à performer
quand ça joue aussi un petit peu sur
l'orgueil d'être d'être passé à côté
d'un événement même championnat du monde
mais vous l'avez rappelé et tous les ans
donc je ne pense pas que ce soit ça soit
totalement dommageable et décevant j'y
vois plutôt le verre à moitié plein en
disant ils se sont ils se sont donné une
occasion mentalement de réagir et donc
d'opérer les réglages également de
manière à être prêts pour les jo si les
g hausse se tienne ça c'est une réaction
de faible lorsque l'on dit on se trouve
des excuses parce que je vous rappelle
quand même que l'on ne devait en devait
à ses jo avec le rsa après les visites
on devait à s'échapper avec modération
et ramener ramener que des médailles
c'était c'était quand même l'objectif
et lorsque l'on tape parler le membre du
comité directeur
j'aime bien qu'olivier jean joseph
julaud toyer ici active et qu'ils ont
sur le plateau à la place de notre ami
yann et quand on entend les autres
nations sont déjà prêtes on va dire
puisque c'est lui même qui l'a dit les
autres nations sont déjà prêtes à ces
mois des jeux olympiques
certes il ya encore cinq mois de
préparation mais le fait de dire alors
qu'on avait quand même des prétentions
et des objectifs pour ces championnats
du monde de ramener des médailles mois
pour moi c'est une contre performance
parce qu'on attendait certes incertaine
notamment malti mathilde de gros ce qui
revient archives renouvelables at-il de
gros c'est la pépite en du snop est
certes en double a été éliminé dès les
huitièmes de finale du tournoi de
vitesse individuelle et elle a été
éliminée en demi-finale du cai voilà
donc deux pour moi quand même pour moi
je dirais que c'est un petit peu la
sonnette d'alarmé
là on s'est un petit peu mis un petit
peu mieux j'ai à dire une bêtise mais
c'était quand même si on s'est mis un
petit peu la pression
donc on n'a plus le choix effectivement
on a cinq mois pour redresser la barre
parce que on est passé à côté de nos
deux noms mondiaux et qui était qui
était prometteur avant où on devait
ramener on avait raflé quelques
médailles et préparer ces jeux
olympiques donc dire maintenant alors je
m'attendais à ce qu'ils disent de sa
pire mais dire maintenant bon mais ça
nous permet de rebondir sur le banc une
douche froide
et puis les jeux olympiques arrivent à
la cc c'est le verre à moitié plein moi
je dirais plutôt le verre à moitié vide
hélène qui vous a convaincu je les deux
parce qu'après ralentirait voilà jean
pierre non mais c'est l'occasion aussi
de faire le point un petit peu on en
était avant les géo et aussi de prendre
un élan pour
un élan
ascendant pour aller aux jo et se dire
voilà on a déjà fait ça et on continue
là c'est bon ben c'est pas c'est pas
autant qu'on l'espérait qu'on avait
pensé donc peut-être vendeurs mettre les
bouchées les bouchées doubles en fait on
ne répète on devrait pas avoir ce petit
creux avant de repartir pour repartir en
direction des 0 et je vous devraient
être notées en fait finalement stéphane
que si on doit se planter ça doit être
maintenant est prêt le jour j
d'abord c'est pas grave à part ce sont
quand même des championnats du monde
mais à partir des deux cyclistes mais
bon il vaut mieux se planter si on doit
se planter autant que ce soit là que pas
répondent présents en région
je rappelle quand même le classement de
ces championnats du monde les pays-bas
sont devant avec 9 médailles dont 6 en
or
il ya ensuite l'allemagne avec huit
médailles dont quatre en or les états
unis sont 3e avec 5 médailles dont deux
en or la france est sixième mais devant
la grande bretagne la france a une
médaille de plus une médaille de bronze
en plus finalement les onglets
généralement fondées mauvais
championnats du monde en février mars et
des bons géo derrière est ce que
finalement c'est pas une stratégie
opérée par la france où ces inconscients
finalement dans ce cas là je serais ce
pas je pense moi qui suis allé prendre
l'exemple anglais quand même ce pas
votre cycle alors les amis lephone
certes mais eux c'est de leur
préparation qu'il le faut c'est c'est
tous les ans les championnats mondiaux
tous les ans il passe un peu à côté
généralement ils sont bons aussi aux jo
voilà donc il inclut dans la préparation
ce creux et on y voit simplement pour
mettre pour régler les derniers détails
nous encore une fois ou alors ou alors
j'ai raté quelque chose mais on n'était
pas là dessus on n'était pas là dessus
on était pas on a des portes il ya une
part de bluff dans cette histoire web
alors là aussi après bien sûr si mes
chevaux échec alors ils jouent aux
échecs
ça y est nous reviennent dujarrier nous
rappelle souvent que luan coeur serait
super sport et que les cyclistes sont
des compétiteurs
la seule question que je me pose
sectionne sur une année olympique est ce
que la préparation mentale et l'acuité
mentale est la même
sur les championnats du monde que sur
les jo qui arrive quatre mois plus tard
sans pouvoir y répondre à 100 % mais il
ya sûrement une petite part de
motivation et a en plus si on y place la
stratégie après il ya là pour le groupe
il ya beaucoup de jeunes également dans
cette équipe de france dé sébastien
vigier des réunionnais l'alma type de
gros ils ont tous moments de 23 ans est
ce que finalement on va pas laisser de
côté finalement ccg au 2020 est passé
directement de 2024 agir et que nous
n'aurons même si c'est même si c'est à
paris même si c'est à paris il faut suer
sur une olympiade et sur des jeux il
faut tout donner
hélas la lettre ça serait ça serait une
erreur une erreur tactique et
stratégique de passer à côté pour se
préparer pour paris parce que on ne se
prépare jamais mieux qu'en complément
anc en gérant au mieux la compétition
sur des jo en conditions réelles de des
preuves vous êtes d'accord et oui
totalement soissons le cyclisme depuis
ils ont baissé plus la même chose paris
c'est du lourd alors continue cette page
résultat pas un record en record pour la
bonne cause au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines titia à bénard
une habitante de bullion licencié à
vélizy a battu ce samedi 7 mars le
record de l'heure sur piste dans sa
catégorie avec 40 points 95 kilomètres
parcourus dans ce record était le 38,28
km nous avions reçu laetitia bénin sur
ce plateau juste avant sont encore j'ai
voulu montrer aux malades et puis aux
familles qu'on peut pratiquer du sport
même du sport intensif tout en suivant
un traitement assez lourd parce que vous
nous présentez justement cette maladie
c'est une maladie inflammatoire des
intestins et
c'est une maladie chronique dont on ne
guérit pas tout comme la maladie de
crohn donc c'est pas repoussé on peut ne
pas avoir poussé pendant plusieurs
années comme être vraiment dit cap et au
niveau 1 un destin grosse fatigue
la question sur ce thème laetitia veux
être un modèle pour les personnes
atteintes de cette maladie au montant
que tout le monde peut le faire at elle
réussi son pari avec ce record oui nous
a été la première à des lignes
évidemment de toutes façons ces gens
mais on porte l'étendard de quelque
chose qu'on voit là qu'on est en avant
des performances qu'on peut y arriver
qu'on essaie de porter une cause on a
tout gagné puis l'allèle elle bat le
record et on parle pas de de peu le bas
quand même de pas mal donc c'est très
bien on peut pas dit enfin elle a tout à
fait tout à fait raison de le faire
cette femme
moi je dis chapeau parce que c'est
balèze ce qu'elle a c'est quand même
nous connaissez oui je connaissais oui
ces maladies qui ou tu te vide s'est
régulièrement hémorragie donc à beaucoup
de sens beaucoup de fatigue
il ya tous les tout ce qui va à côté et
elle surmonte ça pour battre un record
moi je dis simplement chapeau ça me fait
rempli a rappelé
c'est peut-être cet athlète belge
handicapés qui avait des douleurs mais
incroyable incroyable incroyable et qui
lors des compètes et ben il n'y avait
plus rien c'était il n'y avait plus rien
et elle gagne à l'ouvrier voilà
l'oublier il n'y avait plus rien et une
fois que c'était fini ça revenait et
puis malheureusement bon elle a demandé
à ce qu'elle soit euthanasié parce que
c'était plus possible mais moi je dis
bravo à ces gens là quoi jean admiratif
devant tant de courage c'est toujours
déjà déjà la performance sportive par
elle même c'est déjà une exceptionnelle
mais en plus dans les conditions de
maladie c'est encore plus exceptionnel
et extraordinaire et on peut être
qu'admiratif devant ce ce genre de
réalisations sportives
alors elle a réalisé 40 95 km au lieu de
38 28 km pour le précédent record
une performance notable sans vous ça
peut marquer l'histoire du sport de ce
sport pas trop de repères
de repères ils avaient tous les records
entre la voiture encore elle l'a bien
qu'on me dise hélène elle avait bien
souligné c'est quand même plus de deux
kilomètres donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même c'est pas là pas battu sur
sur 50 m donc c'est quand même une belle
performance vu à ce niveau pendant une
heure sans complexe et voilà de battre
un record dans des conditions pareilles
avec un état physique comme elle a cessé
sa en fait qu'il faut retenir
parce que on peut imaginer que si elle
avait pas ces problèmes là on serait pas
à 40,95 on serait sûrement encore à puce
donc moi je dis chapeau
alors le message passe t'il mieux avec
un record forcément à la clé parce que
c'est le message d'un cas où les
véhicules et finalement pour répondre à
reprendre la question c'est de toute
façon c'est une c'est un exemple de
volonté cessé de l'espoir pour les pour
tout l'est pour tous les sportifs et
sportives et qu'il ou elle soit atteint
de n'importe quel d'un porte quelle
maladie voire avoir handicap d'ailleurs
aussi et c'est une femme formidable
message et qui porte un peu plus avec un
record battu bien évidemment parce que
c'est parce que c'est c'est de la
préparation c'est des conditions de
course et c'est là où vraisemblablement
deux ou trois tours de piste de plus que
le que le précédent record donc c'est
oui c'est c'est encore plus marquant est
encore plus impactants avec un record à
la clé
parce qu'en plus dans les reprises
médiatique local et régional
il ya cette histoire là a raconté non
seulement non seulement elle à son son
cet handicap là et cette maladie là et
en plus elle le surmonte avec avec
panache avec courage volonté et ça donne
un record est ce que quand enfin records
comme celui là on fait pour soi ou pour
les autres
finalement je prends les deux les deux
je pense d2 les deux parce qu'il faut il
faut de la vie il faut de la volonté
perso pour y arriver
et après elle porte ce message vraiment
de porter ce message la porte au cic de
l'émulation des villages nature est une
humiliation sportive donc là c'est
vraiment au delà du fait qu'il ya pas
forcément il ya personne sur les pistes
en plus en plus en plus d'elle par
exemple que c'est pas des conditions de
compétition collective mais ccc une
compétition contre elle-même c'est un
challenge contre elle-même qu'elle
réussit pour pouvoir après pousser ce
message et donner donner l'espoir à ceux
qui en ont besoin
c'est d'autant plus difficile qu'elle le
fait non seulement pour le record mais
il ya toute la préparation tous les
entraînements avancée des heures des
heures des jours des mois
demandez votre wii donc on peut aller
très peur que le corrélat virus annuler
son record à quelques jours spectateurs
ça a dû être vraiment difficile pour
elle parce qu'on parle pas que de ses 40
km ce jour là c'est tout ce qu'il ya eu
avant il fallait être sacrément motivé
qui a dû avoir des rechutes ddrrr
descente et des crises donc voilà bravo
stefano visuel fait du coût pour les
deux c'est sa peau elle est pour les je
pense qu'elle le fait avant tout pour
elle je connais beaucoup de personnes
handicapées qui font du sport à haut
niveau
ils voudront ils vous diront pas je fais
du sport pour montrer aux autres que je
peux le faire
non c'est je fais du sport ce j'ai envie
de le faire je vais surmonter ça je
pense qu elle c'est pareil elle s'est
dit je suis capable de battre ce record
et ensuite si ça peut aider les autres
personnes qui ont ma maladie à surmonter
ça pourquoi pas mais je pense qu'avant
tout elle l'a fait pour elle moi je
l'aurais fait pour moi d'hôtel battre
d'autres records ou pas pour qu'on parle
encore plus d'elle et du coup ça cause
par la même occasion jean haja continue
d'autres encore le même au moins le même
l'améliorer on va dire peut-être
l'améliorer un bleu je sais pas si elle
dort avec autre chose je ne connais pas
beaucoup de cyclisme sur piste ou de
cyclisme sur piste donc après au niveau
des records
individuels comme ça il ya vraiment que
le que ce leurre quoique record de
l'heure qui est vraiment quelque chose
en plus qui on en parle de ce genre de
record après je ne suis pas sûr que
trouver un autre recours ce que je
réfléchisse à un autant trouver un autre
corps sur une piste avec avec un vélo je
vois pas ce qu'il ya de plus que leur
donc l'améliorer le sien éventuellement
mais là je crois qu'elle a gardée d'ores
et déjà gagné sébastien stéphane par
stéphane stéphane laviani et et je le
rejoins totalement
c'est avant tout pour elle et parce
qu'elle y est arrivé elle le met en
avant je pense que c'est tout à fait ça
parce qu'elle y est arrivé sa première
motivation n'était pas je veux le faire
pour montrer aux autres je crois que
c'est individuel et ensuite elle est
arrivée elle s'en sert maintenant à bas
cali est sincère c'est pas pour
remporter quelque chose c'est un bon
escient
mais c'est justement pour dire voilà moi
j'y suis arrivé malgré les conditions
des conditions assez difficile très
difficile d'être aligné sur d'autres sur
d'autres compétitions là pour le
collectif avait du monde autour dans sa
discipline sur piste sur piste celle ci
à vélizy en tout cas c'est lé là auréolé
de ce record là s'aligner sur des
compétitions
officielle avec justement la possibilité
d'aller d'aller se frotter aux meilleurs
puis beaucoup de personnes qui ont sa
maladie aussi ils peuvent se dire ah
ouais quand même elle l'a fait peut-être
mais même moi aussi ça pousse
elle y arrive
encore un grand bravo en tout cas
laetitia pour son record on passe
maintenant notre page est découverte
[Musique]
on passe à notre dernière thématique ali
baradji originaire de
voisins-le-bretonneux a une nouvelle
fois remporté le concours de miss
fitness france c'est la troisième fois
qu'elle remporte cette compétition après
2019 et 2018 elle nous présente cette
compétition nous l'avons reçue dans le
7-8 sport du 9 mars
on a des pompes mes épreuves préférées
les tractions on a de la course il ya du
rameur
du développé couché en fait la plupart
des exercices qu'on va retrouver en
salles de sport en fait on les leon les
retrouve sur cette compétition
ce sont plus des épreuves de force ou
d'endurance finalement à moi je dirais
de d'endurance musculaire de résistance
et je pense que pour moi je pense qu'il
s'est quand même essentiellement le
mental qui est mise àl'épreuve parce
qu'on a on a on est souvent tout près du
du candidat d'à côté on a on doit tenir
en fait c'est à dire que on sait que
l'autre est très bon aussi
donc j'ai pour moi c'est au mental qu'on
y arrive à la fin la question sur ce
thème ce concours est il un vrai
concours oui ou non est unanime autour
de la table pierre vous donnera juste
après on évite souvent sur ce plateau
sur à définir qu'est-ce qui est un sport
est ce qui est un loisir en ce qu'il en
est pas là pour le coup un con qu il y a
différents agréé il ya des juges
il ya des athlètes qui s'y préparent qui
s'y entraînent il ya comparaison
compétition donc oui c'est oui c'est un
vrai concours et en plus a priori pas
facile pas facile à remporter cette
dernière émission d'aller parler de ea
sports notamment vous avez été très
critique autour de cette table finale
pour le coup c'est dur est fait pour
vous il ya dépense physique en plus de
la dimension mentale donc oui c'était
oui c'est un vrai sport et donc c'est un
concours pas photo deux parties
trentaine de concurrents de toute la
france d'accord mais on est là de ce
concours est ouvert depuis combien de
temps il aux airs alors il a été créé si
les informations sont bonnes en 2005
donc c
ok je sais fans de bizet qu'est ce que
vous en pensez ce concours assez
intéressant c'est comme le disait pierre
c'est un vrai sport c'est c'est mieux
que le vice porte et même que la boxe là
où il dans ce sens toucher la savate
forme
la savate forme ça ne vous a pas plu non
ça c'est du sport
on y va on carbure genre mais ça envoie
du bois fait attention
non mais là c'est monsieur ccc micro
speed mais mimi elle la course
[Musique]
là c'est complet quand même hein c'est
très complet on a vu un petit peu sur
les images sur ces entraînements les
deux reprises les pompes les tractions
les noms je pense que là là on parle
avant en l'ati soit ici mais là on peut
pour vous parler de sport est-ce que
cali peut être fière de ce qu'elle a
réalisé apparemment c'est ce qu'elle
nous a dit le niveau augmente d'année en
année forcément ce qu'il ya plus de
participants plus de médiatisation
autour de cet événement est ce qu'elle
vous impressionne que ce troisième titre
vous impressionne forcément d'ailleurs
finalement c'est c'est très dur c'est
très dur c'est très dur ça de façon pour
faire de la musculation
je sais que c'est très dur ce genre de
choses mais ça fait depuis 2005 donc
2515 en 15 ans d'existence c'est pas
énorme
sauf qu'on a des disciplines qui sont un
petit peu proches je parle je parle et
obtenant du crossfit et qu'ils soient un
petit peu à la mode qui grandissent de
deux semaines en semaines de mois en
mois hélas ce genre en discipline ya de
plus en plus de gens qui s'y qui s'y
dirige donc de toutes façons elle et
s'est engagé à sa compétition elle
remporte le titre
on ne peut qu'être admiratif c'est elle
est allée au bout qui on le dit souvent
ici elle est allée au bout elle a
remporté ce qui intéresse vers ce type
de disciplines sportives c'est que c'est
ça précède quasiment tous les sports je
m'explique en ayant en disant que la
plupart des de ceux qui font du sport
individuel du sport collectif des sports
collectifs passe à un moment ou un autre
par cette préparation physique la dire
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
fait en addition des preuves pour le
fitness
on le connaît au rugby on le connaît
dans la préparation physique du mois
d'août où vous allez on va les faire des
pompes des tractions du coupeur des
différentes différentes disciplines et
là tout le monde pratique en fait
finalement un moment ou un autre on
pratique la musculation le l'exercice le
cardio le cardio qu'elle fait un moment
ou à un autre ça donne une athlète
complète respect respect pour ça et qui
qui s'entraîne dur pour ce type de
discipline est arrivé à ses fins pour
remporter un concours avec autant de
autant de disciplines exigeantes
chapeau 3 ans d'affilée en plus un gain
de 3 ans un fils moi je dire la petite
information réalise environ 300 à 400
pompe dans une journée
elle travaille justement à l'époque de
pez à l'épreuve de p s
elle donne des cours de zumba également
dans le secteur voisin breton de
montigny-le-bretonneux
et à côté de ça dès qu'elle a un petit
temps mort elle fait des bombes des
tractions voilà ah ouais c'est tout
comme nous
c'est presque rien par rapport à elle ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle se fait comme
exercices divers et variés quand elle
s'entraîne vraiment c'est un petit peu
pour se comment dire se chauffer un peu
et était engourdir pour elle je suis un
chef j'ai passé une information là vous
n'êtes pas mariée mais son mari doit pas
s'ennuyer avec elle ce n'est pas je n'ai
pas d'information là-dessus alors soit
ils sont graves
si c'est pas de la ligue 1 alors est-ce
que dernière question est ce que tout le
monde peut devenir miss 8,9 france ou
pas elaine may votre vie je pense que
oui après en s'entraînant les rouges
je pense que oui oui c'est déjà l'heure
je pense que tout le monde non parce
qu'il faut il faut de la préparation il
faut des certaines une certaine aptitude
physique mais sur le choix de la
discipline tout le monde a fait à un
moment ou un autre des pompes a pas
forcément 300 par jour pompe du duc et
radio les deux reprises le rameur etc
c'est accessible en fait comme comme
discipline donc oui tout on peut
participer de la hanche et ses
performances à l on voit la différence
elle fait 300 pompes par jour pour y
arriver ça c'est pas donné à tous voilà
après c'est progressif
alliés depuis un petit moment elle s'est
entraînée depuis de nombreuses années
sans doute donc c'est une question d'
attaques simultanées moyens mais bon
genre comme on peut le faire à tout le
monde peut le faire
c'est accessible
je précise quand même qu'il y a
également mr fitness français n'y a pas
que sur une puissante voilà donc nous
intéresser les vous inscrire messieurs
vous pourrez également le succès des
deux côtés ou alors mais j'espère y
quelques années que alors c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission va terminer a
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
de l'ancien pilote de f1 michael
schumacher j'ai toujours pensé que vous
ne deviez jamais abandonné que vous
deviez toujours continuer à vous battre
même quand il n'y a qu'une petite chance
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]